so we have a virus no treatment protocol
and no vaccine at this time this was
Hollywood's take on a global health
crisis but according to the world health
organization it might not be far off
this is a scenario which could happen
obviously it hasn't happened yet but we
are seeing more and more cases of where
it is getting close to happening the
threat from the antibiotic resistant
superbugs they say is global serious and
growing heralding the dawn of a
post-antibiotic era and the end of
modern medicine as we knew it
director-general dr. Margaret Chan
warned things as common as strep throat
or a child scratch knee could once again
kill hip replacements organ transplants
cancer chemotherapy would become far
more difficult or even too dangerous to
undertake we cannot allow the loss of
essential antimicrobials essential cures
for many millions of people to become
the next global crisis it's a world sue
Fallon has something of an insight into
her 17 year old daughter Samantha was a
fit and normally healthy a level student
until she was admitted to hospital with
a virus within days mrs. Fallon was
watching her daughter died after
contracting mrs a she started fitting on
the Monday Sunday Monday when they took
a lion out of a knack she went to
intensive care Lisa dated her and then
she died on the Friday afternoon
antibiotics are effectively a selective
poison they target the bacteria in our
bodies and leave the healthy cells alone
but as more of those bacteria become
resistant more antibiotics need to be
phoned and that's where the problem lies
the pipeline for new drugs is running
virtually dry and the finances just
don't stack up to develop more from drug
companies point of view antibiotics are
not an attractive drug class to really
be working on the real moneymakers are
drugs for long-term conditions or
chronic
such as asthma where patients may be on
the drug for life which doesn't stop us
asking for them when we get into the
doctors surgery a lot of our patients
because of the pressures they're under
in their everyday lives feel that they
need everything they can to get better
as quickly as possible their employers
are yelling at them to come back to work
they're feeling terrible they want to
get better as quickly as they can
globally the picture is very mixed in
China doctors are find if they prescribe
to many in India you can just buy them
over the counter and the problem is not
limited to humans more antibiotics and
no use in healthy animals to protect
livestock than an unhealthy humans
worldwide unless we want this in real
life warns the World Health Organization
we must take concerted international
action now Katy stallard Sky News